Helpsters, our goal is to get Lizzie's lizard back home.
Now, who's got an idea, huh?
Mm.
Mr. Primm.
Thank you.
Lizard Lizzie said Karen doesn't like the cold,
so maybe there are places she is more likely to be.
I see.
So if we find out what that is--
Then we can figure out which room Karen might be in.
Yeah.
Oh, we have to find her.
We will find her Mr. Primm.
We will find her, but first we have to do job one,
learn what kind of places Karen likes.
Oh, Scatter, what you got?
Oh, me?
Yeah, you, Scatter.
Oh, well, once we know where to look, we find Karen.
Yeah, we do, and that's job two, find Karen.
Then once we find Karen, we can put
her back inside of her home.
Oh, we call her home a habitat.
I learned that from Billy Bob.
You're right about that.
Job three, return Karen to her habitat.
All right.
Helpsters, we have our plan.
We've got the plan, got the plan.
We've figured it out.
We've got the plan.
What happens when we've got the plan?
We give a happy shout just because we can.
Woo-hoo!
Well, team, now how do we find out what kind of places
Karen likes?
I have an idea.
Ooh.
Wah.
Whoa.
Hello all-knowing monster.
Oh, welcome back to Wisdom Mountain.
What are the answers that you seek?
What kind of places does Karen the lizard like to live in?
Warm places with trees.
Learn what kind of places Karen likes, check.
One job done.
Two more to go.
You do know all things.
I know.
Karen likes warm places with trees.
Oh, we can use that to make a rule.
If a room is warm and it has trees, then Karen will like it.
What about the snowy forest room?
Yeah, but it's not warm.
Yeah, that's the snow.
Ah.
It needs to be both.
Oh, yes.
Then let's keep looking.
The jungle room is warm.
And it has trees.
If the room is both warm and has trees,
then the lizard likes it.
Yeah.
Jungle room ahoy.
All right.
Karen?
Ah, the jungle room.
She'll love it.
Karen?
Uh, there she is.
Find Karen, check.
Two jobs done, one more to go.
Quick, let's get her back in her habitat.
Yeah.
Yeah, grab that.
OK, come on.
Come on.
Let's go.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh.
Karen ran away.
Well, how do we get her back?
Well, I always show up for food.
Good, but how do we find out what foods Karen likes to eat?
I have an idea.
Karen eats insects or leafy green vegetable.
Karen likes insects or leafy green vegetables.
Oh, OK.
Well, I don't have any insects.
Do you have any insects?
I don't have any.
What are we supposed to do if we don't have any insects,
for goodness sake's?
Well, now hold on Mr. Primm.
Now, Heart said they Karen eats insects
or leafy green vegetables.
Or.
Yeah, yeah.
Now, we don't have any insects.
But if we find a leafy green vegetable,
we might still have a chance.
Exactly, yes.
Mr. Primm, shall we go search the kitchen?
We shall, Mr. Scatter.
Cody and I should stay here and make sure Karen does not leave.
Yeah.
Now, remember the rule, if it is green
and a vegetable and leafy, then it is a food Karen likes.
Got it.
Let's see what I got.
Oh, Mr. Primm, how about this?
It's my favorite vegetable, collard greens.
La-la.
It's green and a vegetable and leafy.
Karen will like it.
We did it!
Let's take it to her.
Yes, let's.
Oh.
Oh, is it this way?
There's a door--
No, that way No, maybe it's this way.
OK, the food is in the habitat.
Look, it's Karen.
Ah.
Just look, there's some food for you and you'll love it.
Go into her habitat and--
She's inside.
[INAUDIBLE]
Welcome home little one.
Return Karen to her habitat, check.
All the jobs are done.